pour
aulas n'est pas nécessaire d'aimer le
foot pour se délecter à la lecture des
fortes paroles de thierry roland et jean
michel larqué
réunis en un petit volume de la
collection de poche point virgule au
seuil
tout à fait jean-michel abondance et
formules incongru que favorise le direct
quand elles ne sont pas franchement
incompréhensible
les espagnols distille ont un peu avalé
la trompette
amateur de formules cocasse à la limite
de l'absurde
roland et larqué sont par exemple les
auteurs de ces admirables aphorismes la
défense en ligne de l'uruguay c'est pas
vraiment la sécurité sociale ou encore
si on ne s'appelle pas paul à tottenham
on ne joue pas mais voici le plus beau
dialogue mais pourquoi ils vont en
arrière jean michel mais parce qu'il ne
peut pas aller de l'avant
c'est d'une logique implacable en
matière de géographie humaine
nos amis sont également expert
l'autrichien est vigilant l'irlandais
est vaillant le suédois est magnanime et
le portugais bricoleur a le sport fait
de société les éditions de la halle
baron public un forte intéressante album
consacré au stade de colombes où se tint
en 1924 les jeux olympiques de paris et
vous connaissez le titre de ce livre mon
cher jean michel tout à fait thierry les
yeux du stade